la crise de la coved 19 pourrait avoir
un impact de plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars sur les profits
d'hydro-québec cette année et donc sur
les dividendes versés au gouvernement
c'est ce qu'a indiqué aujourd'hui dans
le cadre d'une conférence virtuelle à la
chambre de commerce du montréal
métropolitain
la pdg ce fibre reçu notre invité ce
soir bonsoir madame reçu mon sens
monsieur fillon
vous êtes en place maintenant depuis
quoi un peu plus de deux mois
comment ça se passe comment ça se passe
chez hydro à la tête d'hydro-québec
mais en fait chi où ça se passe comme
dans toutes les entreprises en fait ici
au québec à travers le monde je utiliser
l'image plutôt aujourd'hui on a tous une
rivière à descendre on est à kaya qui
sait de l'ovi je ne reviens jamais été
des dessins en vue et on n'a pas le
choix de descendre
y'en à gauche et des tourbillons puis au
sortir de ça on espère qu'il va y avoir
une accalmie pic sera ça aura l'occasion
pour nous de reprendre un peu notre
souffle mais pour tout le monde
présentement le sais mais ça c'est dans
les circonstances
ça se passe bien mais pourquoi on parle
de centaines de millions de dollars de
profits de moins due à la coved 19 de
quelle façon lakovic 19 affecte hydro
québec
d'abord avec la consommation de la
demande c'est la première des premiers
impacts que ce soit ici au québec
couché sur nos marchés d'exportation ça
c'est une chose
deuxième des choses un pas que les
bénéfices aussi parce que on a dû mettre
sur pause des projets en immobilisations
des projets qui auraient été capitalisée
lorsqu'une main d'oeuvre travaille sur
un projet capitalisables ça passe dans
les coûts globaux du projet quand on est
sur pause main de velours elle est
toujours disponible et en attendons
qu'elle passe à la dépense vient donc
affecter le bénéfice quand elle met
essentiellement c'est une diminution de
la demande sur le marché québécois
légère rouge dans le marché résidentiel
mendes ou commerciales bassin industriel
et à peu près 5 points 6 % de réduction
des mandats et donc au lieu d'un
bénéfice net de deux milliards 9,1
millions cette année on fera voir vers
quoi
en fait j'ai êtes présent un chapeau cpo
l'un comme hésitation c'est qu'on ne
sait pas encore quel va être le rythme
de la reprise
alors plutôt que de donner des chiffres
qui sont dans une fourchette qui soit 1
précise qu'on sait c'est qu'il va y
avoir un impact déjà de plusieurs
centaines de millions on pense qu'elle
va être contenue à l'intérieur du
milliardaire fait qu'on n'est pas dans
ces eaux là mais quand même savoir un
impact qui est très significatif qui est
pas avec lesquels on peut travailler
mais donc c'est une réalité chez nous
comme partout comme partout là il ya des
projets verts le mène des projets verts
vers l'état de new york aussi et un plan
stratégique à l'international
est ce que tout ça est sur pause est ce
que tout ça est sûr révision
présentement en fait des bouts du plan
stratégique qu'on va accélérer des boues
qui n'existaient pas qu'on va enclencher
que des boues qui existaient qu'on met
carrément sur porge
je vais vous faire sourire pour nous il
l'est les etats unis c'est pour
l'international non pas qu'on veut
annexer les états unis mais les états
unis pour nous c'est la cour arrière
c'est le voisinage on considère ce
marché là comme on considère l'ontario
et les marchés des provinces maritimes
il ya définitivement une peau sur les
grandes initiatives internationales
visant des acquisitions pour toutes
sortes de raisons notamment le fait que
le marché exemple les les gens qui s'y
précipitent avec leur font aujourd'hui
le fonds à des coûts de capital très
faible des rendements attendus qui sont
franchement très faible pour lequel on
n'a pas de création de valeur alors nous
on n'est pas des justement de fonds ont
investi de manière industrielle société
pris par des mis avec la pandémie
aujourd'hui franchement tous les efforts
toute la concentration le capital se
reconcentre l'eau sur notre territoire
de base qui qui est le québec de
nord-est américain les provinces
atlantiques et est ce que vous prévoyez
un retour à la normal guy mais là pour
hydro-québec bientôt l'an prochain et
quelles sont vos prévisions par rapport
à fort je sais pas tous ces coins là
normal monsieur fillion par les entrées
de voir quelle va être parce qu'il ya
des coups qui arrive à court terme à
moyen terme et à plus long terme
alors qu'elle va être l'effet de
répercussions dans l'économie québécoise
bien malin
les gens et qui peuvent le dire nous ce
qui importe évidemment ces campus
approvisionner notre marché de la
manière la plus concurrentielle possible
on veut contribué au rebond économique
du québec
on réalise des projets d'investissement
hollande devance alors par exemple on
est des projets de pérennité sur nos bas
âge pour en assurer la durée de vie
prolongée ont les devants ces projets là
de manière à investir plus rapidement
dans l'économie à la donne au relais du
gouvernement du québec du tout à la
demande
à la demande de l'équipe de direction
environnement d'accélérer les projets en
ce moment en fait le gouvernement
demande contribué au rebond économique
du québec et pour soins différents
outils et nous mêmes on volontariste on
a regardé sa vie comme équipe de
direction on a des relations comme
n'importe qui avec nos actionnaires
mais ce sont là ce sont des décisions
que nous prenons nous comme équipe de
direction
encore une fois c'est on travaille
depuis quelques temps sur deux ouvrages
qui sont ou tard des manic pour pour en
prolonger la durée des pour en améliorer
la capacité aussi et donc on voit les
devancer ce sont des ouvrages devraient
faire c'est payant pour hydro québec en
ce sens qu'on va augmenter la capacité
productive puisse et intelligente pour
le rebond est carrément du québec à là
c'est pas à la demande du gouvernement
nous manque fois rien de spécifique et
ont eu un appel est d'ailleurs ce qui
était demandé si fait du mieux que vous
pouvez avec ce que vous avez vous avez
nommé martin brochu
claudine bouchard et johan du hem au
comité de direction donc plus de femmes
là dans les postes de direction est ce
que vous avez l'intention de faire aussi
une classe comme ça aux minorités
visibles
je vous en parle bien sûr compte tenu de
ce dont on parle présentement de racisme
systémique notamment dans les
institutions
certains sont d'accord d'autres pas
d'accord quel est votre match par
rapport à ça bah écoutez d'abord c'est
important pour moi qu'on arrive en zone
2 paritaire du comité de direction n'est
pas encore tout à fait égalitaire en
étant au paritaire donc avec l'ajout de
ces deux femmes nous sommes cinq
maintenant on compte comité de direction
qui en compte douze personnes
10 maps and comité très blanc on manque
de diversité de minorités visibles
nous allons travailler puis enfin là
dedans je ma vision elle est comme
l'avancé des femmes en égalité au sein
d'une entreprise il faut travailler au
sens noble du terme
l'entonnoir des talents très tôt alors
si on veut des gens l'équipe de
direction de minorités il faut être
capable de faire progresser ces gens là
au sein de l'organisation
aujourd'hui ce que je comprends puis
encore là je ne sais pas tout ce que
j'arrive en poste qu'il ya beaucoup à
apprendre ce que je comprends
aujourd'hui c'est que dans la grande
région de montréal par exemple la main
d'oeuvre d'hydro-québec est à peu près
de 16 pour sa occupés par des minorités
visibles
l'objectif que nous avons de manière
globale et d'être globalement au québec
à 19 sur l'ensemble du québec on est à
peu près à 8 points 6 9 pour ça donc on
a encore de la place au niveau de
l'équipe de direction peut
éventuellement comité de direction
définitivement qu'on va voir davantage
de représentation et on va le faire de
manière déterminée structuré avec des
plans et une reddition de compte pour à
tout le monde
sa mère et son chien mais d'abord au
comité de direction à ce moment le faire
pas pour faire plaisir une société b
parce qu'on y croit et la diversité
c'est une valeur qui nous est cher
maintenant il faut monter en régime et
pas de doute merci beaucoup madame reçu
ça me fait plaisir à revoir furieux